she's like that's the only red flag and
I go I'm sorry what's the only red flag
that he wants a family as a red flag for
her that's life that's a life goal yeah
do you know what I mean she definitely
doesn't understand because like he's
been to jail
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to Big mood
we got our beautiful guest Jay here
I am so happy that she's here and I'm
sure you guys have been loving her on
this channel
um we also have Nikki
now I don't know what to do because she
was like going like oh we're friends
again and then I think I threw her back
off oh my God
I'm Tiff by the way because you didn't
know uh today we're going to be talking
about things that are shared as red
flags but in reality they're just things
that are normal and then we should just
stop shaming people for if that makes
sense like stop using the word red flag
so much kind of like stop using the word
narcissist so much for every little
thing right yeah so a Reddit user posed
a question what is widely considered a
red flag but actually is not
so do you guys have any off the top of
your head
jump start me okay yeah get my juices
going yeah probably do you have triggers
too
so
um I'm gonna go ahead and and
preemptively thank my sister uh for all
the content that I'll come up with for
this episode because she uh just
recently met someone that she's been
with for a bit but
before that has had horrible luck with
guys and it's just red flag after
another it's me I'm your sister that she
ignores okay
sir she ignores nope and then like I
don't know what happened she's not a
mongolo like she like she and I'm like
what the [ __ ] dude like you're telling
me all this now this is so clear like
yeah so
so she there was a guy she was dating
and um
she's like yeah I mean
and she she's known for kind of using
the wrong term for things okay like she
doesn't like she doesn't have the
definition of words maybe I don't know
you know but just basically my husband
just started using Gaslight for
everything that's just lying like yeah
you just like just hold the line outside
yeah
honey look it up
so she she told me that there was a guy
she was dating and they they met and
she's like We're super open with each
other like what I love is like it was so
easy to talk to him and my sister is not
as like communicative as I am like I'll
talk to anyone about anything which I'm
sure everyone has figured out by now but
she's very like very very shut off you
know and she she'll share to impress but
if there's something she feels like
she's gonna get judged for she doesn't
say anything so she's working on that
right and so and she's like nine years
younger than me she's a huge age yeah
that makes sense yeah so she hasn't kind
of lived life's experiences to teach her
that she needs to open her mouth you
know what I mean like anyway they have
the first date and he says how he wants
a family and he wants to have kids you
know he wants to get married and she
does doesn't want that okay she doesn't
want any kids she's okay with getting
married but she definitely has decided
she wants no it's me I'm your sister
yeah that's how it is so then I said did
you did you tell him that so she's like
no oh okay I go oh well that's something
you definitely want to say because this
guy's looking for a life partner right
I'm saying it's kind of a deal breaker
yes yeah so she's like I mean well she's
like that's the only red flag and I go
I'm sorry what's the only red flag
that he wants a family as a red flag for
her that's her life that's a life goal
yeah do you know what I mean she
definitely doesn't understand why
because like he's been to jail yeah you
know what I mean like he like this is
just like a personal desire of his this
is not a red flag this is actually it's
not even a bad thing yeah just because
you don't want that exactly you you not
opening your [ __ ] mouth is the red
flag
so yeah that's the first and then I
probably have some more of those but
that's so she's thinking red flag means
like for us to work out yes
red flag is just a general bad kind of
stop sign for this person's probably not
good to date yes yes like and then she
breaks up with them and they've dated
for months and months and months and
finds out that she runs out she runs a
store uh she's a manager of like a
skincare line and the store next to her
is like a golf something or other the
woman who works in that store not only
dated this guy but is his ex-wife so he
was married and never said anything and
I said that my dad
yeah okay wow so I was like I was like
you need to get like what do you get
women in the same Plaza yeah no here's
the [ __ ] I was like did you guys meet
there she goes no I go this is bananas
this is like a weird coincidence
yeah and he was a golf instructor okay
so now this makes more sense the essay
would be together yeah but like I was
like how do you not like this is not
what a red flag is a red flag is is you
being shut down and not being you know
not talking about being authentic that's
something that you need to work on but
like that's a red flag on his end yeah
that you're actually providing red flags
at the guys that you have in your back
[ __ ] pocket you're like ready and
then you're like yeah
she and she's like she's like no I mean
like it's just the only red flag was
that he wants three kids I'm like I
don't what does he want to have them and
raise them in a basement that's a red
flag
definitely that's crazy that's so funny
so uh one that I have here is a single
guy with a cat I'm not a monster God
damn it okay I swipe left on single guys
with cats sorry
um
no wonder it took you so long I'm sorry
Electric in the room is left no
yeah what's swipe right is what right is
Mr Right
do you think that's why Tinder made left
go away because of Beyonce no I don't
think so I think it makes sense no like
left as you left and like right you're
Mr right yeah yeah I like that yeah okay
that's okay we can remember left oh but
then the ring is on okay
fingers
[Applause]
you said left to the right whatever you
know what I'm saying no I don't I'm
asking you genuinely you take the photo
and swipe it to the right yes
or you take your thumb and you swipe it
to the left if you don't pause one
second sorry additional information
needed so when you have the photo it
says cat owner like how much information
I want to hear why it's wrong it's not
wrong it just doesn't work for me
but can we just
three of us are married I think we could
safely say if you see a picture of a guy
in the profile pic he chose he's holding
a [ __ ] cat left get out of here I'm a
cows too but why are we holding in the
picture like hey we'll date me maybe it
is to filter out these people
a man with a cat seems like he has a
limp dick I'm sorry that's not true
[Music]
and I have exhibited although I did I
did have I did marry a dog person and
converted him to a cat person so it's
like me exactly I don't think you'd make
him seem like a cat man
he's doing this one because I feel like
the purpose of the dating app is to find
a person why are we posing with the
animal well what if you're like your
first impression it's fine that he has
an animal it's not about that I'm just
not like a I'm not attracted to men that
are so
like in line with feet yeah like I don't
know the the feline thing energy doesn't
mix with yeah and I'm not I don't want
an artsy husband or do you man I want a
man that's gonna [ __ ] like kill a
T-Rex and barbecue it and [ __ ] bang
me over the head and take me to his cave
like that's what I need they can like
they can have those people they do but
they're like but they're like they don't
they have like tigers yeah they don't
have oh there we go I guess my
boyfriends have all had cats what yeah
but she wants like every series
all of them
she's like okay maybe
so funny it's not a red flag that a guy
I would say though like I was really
scared of a guy that I fell in love with
like being allergic to my cats because I
would not choose him over my cats no
that would be sad because I'm like well
I really love some I love him but you
have to live in a different house that's
right would you have considered yourself
a cat person Casey no right
so that's what we end up having two cats
because I'm like this home needs an
animal wife and I've always wanted a dog
my entire life I've never had one but a
goldfish yeah it starts
cuddly that's true I mean it is yeah
the weirdest that is no reptile guys
dude constrictor and you're like what
the [ __ ] like no we had a Red Tail Bow
there's only one bow there was this guy
that was trying to date me he had an eel
and I was like weird I can't be in this
room and he told me that I'd escaped
once
[Music]
sink do they have feet no no it jumped
out of it slithered the [ __ ] out of its
tank I'm like I was trying to eat you
that's a new story I haven't heard of it
right now you're just committing suicide
yeah how do we survive well he found it
like I guess luckily he liked the eel
but not for me unfortunately he worked
at a pet store oh
yeah uh no he like and then he also had
a tank that were live rocks though that
grew I'm sorry what yeah it is his pet
live wrong
they grow algae or some [ __ ] I don't
know they grow [ __ ] on it under the
water like so you have to have the water
at a certain like like pH balance wait
they're actual animals like I get like
maybe like you know like CNN type [ __ ]
like would grow on the Rock but you have
to like kind of foster it so it grows
like its own ecosystem weird it's like a
[ __ ] what are those things outside of
Hawaii
they're rocks and then like so it's like
the baby the baby version is just like
like some Moss type stuff kind of starts
to grow on it wow he's like so excited
about that and then he had a fish that
laid a bubble nest in the corner and she
was like really protective of it and he
was like so stoked on that okay
I'm telling you fish people you did not
have been wearing this man right now I
didn't even date him thank God like we
were kind of like coping through we were
both going through a breakup so we were
like friends hanging out and like he
would
this thing really tripped me out and
also he told me how to foot fetish so it
was like I'm out I'm just saying like
those red flowers
you can count those 100 I actually had a
crush on his brother but his brother was
in a relationship but it's wow you're a
red red flag for a little bit that would
be my sister like I really like this guy
but he's in a relationship it's like
it's the only reason
his wife is the only red flag
that's funny all right next one jealousy
it's a human emotion feeling jealous
jealousy isn't a red flag now punching
the wall or taking that feeling of
jealousy out on a person is a red flag
and then someone else replied I 100
agree with this if anything admitting to
jealousy and being able to communicate
those natural feelings in a healthy way
and without hostility should be a
massive green flag even if your feelings
are unfounded irrational feelings are
still feelings of course if it goes too
far like not wanting your partner to be
friends with the opposite sex it's a red
flag but that's the case for basically
everything but it's I disagree and agree
let's hear it
I think from my own personal experience
of like I was used to be a jealous
person and I'm not now and I do think
jealousy to some degree is a red flag
because it's indicative of
and you have to know a little bit about
like kind of human behavior but it's
indicative of
there's a reason why they're jealous the
person's jealous right like when I was
jealous it was because I had things I
was doing that I shouldn't have been
doing not necessarily cheating but
things in a similar band that bothered
me that I had done before to someone
else because if I didn't have those
things I might not necessarily feel that
way I wouldn't want anything on it you
know what I mean like okay let's
whatever and however the thing I do
agree with is communicating about it
because I'm also big online yes
communication is like you know the thing
that solves everything I feel like like
if you just keep communicating about
something so I think that if the
person's willing to be like look I have
this going on I don't necessarily know
why because you may not know why you
feel those things and that's okay it's
okay to feel you just you don't know why
and you're like I feel like this I don't
know why I feel like this a perfect
example of this was right after I had
the baby obviously you know right after
you have a baby you don't you don't have
the best self-esteem in terms of
yourself physically you know you're like
recovering from all of that and so and
you can't you know be intimate for a
while because you're healing like it's a
whole thing and my husband had was
talking to a friend of ours and just was
like yeah and he like put his hand on
her shoulder and I was like I don't like
that so later I was like I know this is
so dumb and you would never do anything
like this I have nothing to worry about
but I just didn't like that because
there's like no physical contact with us
right now yeah and I'm so tired and I'm
hormonal and it's so dumb and it's not
there's no reason for me to be upset
about this but it just was like I'm
she's into touch my shoulder like that
and he's like and he was like babe that
is totally ridiculous but it's no of
course you don't I get that like I
understand is this communicating
feelings yeah I not said anything and I
hung on to it yeah
and it would have become something way
bigger than just like I didn't like that
you just physically had a contact with
someone's body you know what I mean I
think that's all it was but that I
wasn't like jealous I was more like I
just wanted like attention and I didn't
have any physical closeness with my
husband because we just had a baby like
two weeks ago you know what I mean like
dude communication's so it's so
important I cannot emphasize and I will
tell you like I feel like you can have a
relationship last into eternity if you
just communicate about everything yeah
don't hang on to [ __ ] like I'm a big
believer in that but earlier
relationships and earlier times where I
felt jealous I can go back and spot the
times and go like yeah because you know
what in another relationship I was doing
some [ __ ] [ __ ] I should never I lied
about something so it's like a
projection like I had like they had
something I wasn't communicating right
that's what made me jealous you know
what I'm saying yeah so that's why I
feel like on one hand yes it's a massive
green flag to communicate through that
because you could actually come out the
other side and not feel jealous anymore
people talked about it right and you see
that your jealousy was totally like not
warranted right and hopefully in most
cases but at the same time I do think
that being jealous and the person is not
talking about it could be a red flag
depending on that person in their life
of something that they're hiding like
they haven't healed that part like they
haven't done the self work yet exactly
and like that's just like people being
at a different point in their life
exactly yeah I agree with that for sure
I don't know if like jealousy always
stems from that though I mean I like if
I felt jealous like I don't think that
I've ever really done anything where I
was like oh this was I shouldn't have
been doing this now I'm holding on to it
now I'm like oh are you doing it too
like I don't well the other reason she
said I relate to which is the insecurity
part yeah that's the reason yeah I feel
like you you're lacking something yeah
that someone else has really really when
I said doing something I shouldn't be
doing yeah the my the key point for me
on that is like that you're not
communicating about because if you talk
about it it you usually find that it
goes away like when I said something to
my husband about it I was like okay yeah
this is as I'm saying it I'm going I
sound so silly but I feel like that
you're self-aware but yeah it doesn't
take away the feelings right yeah but
like but if you're hanging on to it and
you don't say anything the jealousy gets
worse and worse and worse and I think
that
and it's a personality trait but it
could be confused with the red flag it's
like I'd rather be with somebody who can
communicate about anything on that to me
and feel safe enough to talk to me
because if they don't that's more of a
red flag because if something weird does
happen on a totally disrelated area and
they're not willing to communicate with
me about it that could be a bigger
problem yeah you know what I mean so I
do things finding someone that's like
willing to communicate about things and
being open is so important in that
regard you know and it's also like like
sometimes like the root of someone call
saying that oh she's jealous that's a
red flag like for me in my ex
relationship
um like my ex was like actually going
and like going out and lying to me and
going and meeting up with other girls
yeah and like I had this like first
feeling it made me like look through his
phone and like I like things that I
never would do that was a perception
yeah you know what I mean like you knew
something and then like I was right and
I was it was more about being lied to
not that I was jealous of these girls
yeah but more like that he was lying to
me about it and then it also was like
damn like why does he feel the need like
am I not satisfying like yeah it creates
insecurity yeah sure
I relate to that yeah when I was 21 I
dated someone that was twice my age he
was 42. wow it was right before I moved
here
very big red flag and he started doing
that and he didn't tell me for a long
time and at the end of that the thing
that destroyed me the most was it's not
that you went and did something like
that yeah it's that you because you go
out and do something like that I would
hope that it's tearing you up inside
that you can't even look me in my face
that you have to go babe I [ __ ] up
yeah then you came home every [ __ ]
day and looked me in my eye and said I
love you before I went to sleep yes
and it made me feel like nothing exactly
exactly so that is like and and I did
have that like imagine I'm going I'm
half your age and I'm not good at what
is happening yeah do you know what I
mean like the insecurity of that right
of going like wow I'm I'm that much of a
[ __ ] idiot that you you're just gonna
come lie every day yeah are you kidding
me that's way worse because there's
there's this very belittling demeaning
like you're nothing you know it's
different than like at least give me the
the thing to go like this is tearing me
I have to tell you if I if we were to
get together and get married what
happens when I'm 40 what happens when
I'm like are you like trading me in for
like yeah I'm like I'm 24 right now like
why why is this happening yeah yeah
that's what I was like I was like I'm
half your age any other guy your age
would this is like a Dr what is going on
yeah you know what I mean like oh my God
lucky to have a girlfriend in their 20s
lucky to have someone so dumb yeah
exactly exactly that's horrible yeah so
yeah that you explain it really
perfectly is that feeling of feeling
like you're nothing yeah that's what
creates the biggest insecurity and makes
you feel like but to me that's not the
same because I because there's jealousy
where there's possession yes yeah where
they're like trying to control you
because they're so like jealous of what
whoever you're spending your time with
that's not them or like even if you're
doing an activity it's not spending time
well that seems to be projected those
people tend to be the the ones that are
cheating or doing something
that's what I was referring like yeah
the hidden things like yeah those kinds
of people that are true too much yeah it
doesn't make sense yeah they're so
jealous yeah like coming from like a
weird they want all your happiness to
come from them yeah or maybe maybe it's
not that they've done something or are
the ones also doing something wrong but
maybe it's just like codependency or
abandonment or something that's like
some other mental issue that they
they're not gonna be interior and
themselves like even if they're not
guilty of anything like yeah just also
it's just severe lack so I think that's
why anytime jealousy comes up people are
instantly like oh severe lack something
yeah but because also I think there's
different types of it right like there's
that the person that's a crazy like I
have to control you where it's like
there's a nastiness attached to the
jealousy right and like a vindictiveness
yeah but then there's like jealousy that
you just want attention like my best
friend did something with a friend of
hers and mentioned in the video this is
my best friend I was like well I thought
I was your best friend yeah like I
didn't have any like I want to [ __ ]
kill that girl yeah yeah yeah yeah but I
was just like kind of hurt yeah oh man
yes we're 39 but you're still yeah
I get more jealous of that kind of stuff
for like people that like are my friends
or whatever they will go and hang out on
the weekend and I didn't get invited and
I'm like I get more jealous of that than
I than I do over like but it's like it's
like a you were not included like I
wanted attention yeah jealousy not like
a this is not a like you're and you're
like Nat and you're like yeah that's a
difference Dynamic to that yeah exactly
like that's the one that I was saying
earlier is like like really true evil
jealous is a whole I think is it just
because there's something behind this
yeah that's the red flag yeah exactly
don't conflate the flags
yes I'm sure there's people who would
agree it's like a light pink flag yeah
self-care is always top of mind for me
but in between meditation sessions and
trips to the yoga studio or nail salon
how often are you taking care of all of
your needs if you know what I mean
transport your mind to a world where you
can relax and treat yourself to your
deepest desires with Dipsy self-care has
never sounded better Dipsy is an app
full of hundreds of short sexy audio
stories designed by women for women they
bring scenarios to life with immersive
soundscapes and realistic characters
find stories about an intriguing
co-worker with a British accent or
hooking up with your hot yoga instructor
new content is released every week so in
between listening to your favorite
stories again and again you can always
find something new to explore for
listeners of the show dipsy's offering
an extended 30-day free trial when you
go to dipsystories.com mood that's 30
days of full access for free when you go
to dip e s e a stories.com slash mood
dipsystories.com mood alright next one
going to therapy someone that is working
that's a red flag someone that is
working on themselves and is either
financially well off or has good
insurance Swoon like that shouldn't be a
red fighting your baby boomers or what
yeah the previous generations it was
like you're going to a shrink
something's wrong with you oh is that
like what it was a red flag to like
people like that probably that's what
I'm guessing that yeah it's like you
hemorrhaging from your [ __ ] arm and
going to the ER it's like you have to go
yeah
I think it's it's
completely opposite of red flag to be
willing to be aware enough that you need
some help
with that next one weird dare you gather
tools to be for self-improvement that's
crazy
uh being clingy now actually being
clingy and overstepping boundaries is a
red flag but these days a lot of things
that are perceived as clingy are just
people showing genuine interest as
opposed to trying to play it cool okay
World thing it's kind of like oh he
texted me the next day instead of
[ __ ] waiting three days he's cleaning
you know like maybe that's like kind of
what they're talking about you know like
do you feel like that uh if I like them
I don't feel like yeah yeah
right it's like it's I think it's stuff
like when a guy shows genuine interest
and he's like not playing games or
something or a girl you know she's like
oh can we hang out this weekend and next
weekend because I just want to see you
and I might be like oh she's so clingy
you know but it's just because he's not
but if he really likes the person yeah
you know and you guys know like when I
first started dating I would be like oh
he texted me good morning like get out
yeah and then this guy that I just kind
of started talking to texting me every
day and I never thought like yeah this
is too much I was like oh that's funny
you know yeah
yeah that's true if you like them my
sister had this too where she was like
it's been days and they haven't done
like so then just text them what is all
these bullshits if you like the guy say
[ __ ] hey how's it going I had a good
time like why is that not okay you know
what I mean actually why are we waiting
Flags no pun intended uh was my husband
texting me back so because yeah his last
name's green oh that's right yeah like a
me like my ex that was the one thing
that just really bothered me that he
would take so long to text back like
yeah what do you do like why is it
taking that long I know you're on your
phone you're on [ __ ] Instagram like
yeah it's just like a simple question
it's not like I need to talk to you for
hours like I want you to answer my
question yeah and um and my my now
husband uh so fast with the freaking
touches and Crosses I was like I just
love communication yes yes I'm the same
way if somebody takes too long to get
back to me I'm like
yeah who doesn't have I have my phone on
me also all the time and I have to
understand some people don't yeah but
like I mean like two hours is acceptable
but like if I'm just like hey are we
hanging out for dinner and then you go
till the next day and don't forget I
still haven't eaten what's going on yeah
I'm guilty yeah so yeah I'm literally
I've gotten significantly worse texting
since Luca but with dating no no yeah
but no just like as a person like yeah
yeah exactly yes you don't have any time
to date now because yeah
a single guy with a cat has no [ __ ]
excuse me
that's so funny well maybe he's busy
with his extracurricular activities like
shoveling [ __ ] making little cat
sweaters yeah no have you ever owned a
cat
that's dog people [ __ ] okay
booties for cats
all right next one left men having
female friends a lot of girls get
jealous but if it's a real relationship
and not a bunch of x's and hookups it
actually shows women consider them
reliable and good people to have around
I'm a little I get it I get it but also
I'm a little wondering like because I
don't have any men that I just keep
around in my life as a friend and so
it's just hard for me to personally
understand that but I'm not saying it's
not valid but I do kind of lean more
towards like why do you need a bunch of
female friends I don't know like if it's
one and it makes sense like oh we were
in college together like we went through
[ __ ] hell together there's like a
whole War Story like my sister or
something but then like to have all
these female friends I don't know if I
like it I don't know I guess it could be
kind of similar to how girls like
there's girls that just have nothing but
guy friends like they tested on me so
yeah I don't get it that was me yeah I
had a lot of guy friends too but I feel
like it's just one of those things where
they just tend to feel more comfortable
with the opposite sex as a friendship
rather than their like that that movie I
love you man where it was like he felt
more comfortable with girls and like
yeah exactly in his life but then he
didn't have any guy best friends so like
when he was trying to get his groomsmen
he didn't have any groomsmen yeah
um yeah you know Steve was the first
person I ever dated that like set a rule
that was like Hey so we don't need to
hang out with people that are the
opposite sex like just as friends right
and I was like why like I don't know
like I've never I always had lots of guy
friends and then he kind of like broke
it down where he was just like yeah I
mean like there's really not a need
unless like it's there's like a common
interest like you guys are going to you
know some thing together that you're
like I mean like right now I play poker
so if I went to poker with someone like
he wouldn't care but if like you're
going out to just like hang with a group
of guys like why like why are you why is
it you with a bunch of guys just
randomly hanging out and like and I was
like oh yeah I guess I never thought of
it that way and then he's like you know
and then there's the other thing where
I've been the guy where like a lot of
the guys just want to hook up they're
just waiting in the wings for that girl
to like fall into their lap and I was
like huh yeah every time I got their
breakup I definitely got hit up by a
bunch of those guys that were waiting in
the wings that like I thought we were
just friends but then we'd like now I'm
single homie randomly hooked up at a
party like so I was like okay maybe
there's some validity to that and I
don't I don't know I just kind of like
he was the first guy that ever proposed
that and uh it's been
I think that's been pretty it's been
pretty cool but I I don't I can see both
sides because I was the one that had
like all the all the guy friends yeah so
you would consider that a red black for
you in your dating World
um I would have to understand like why
there's friends and like yeah yeah but
yeah I mean immediately if I'm just
thinking like oh why do you have female
friends like what purpose are they
serving yeah like what do you do
together like what like emotionally how
close are you like what is this that's a
red flag yeah yeah to have like the
opposite sex friends okay so I have two
two different people one of them's my
husband so when I first moved here there
was a couple guys I was still talking to
and I grew up I used to only hang out
with guys like I was very tomboyish and
I was a kid yeah but when I moved here I
had some guy friends I was still talking
to but most of them I had either dated
or hooked up with right and I was having
trouble finding like a guy to date here
like a new like a new relationship you
know and then I was like you know God
it's kind of weird like I do feel like
when I talk to these guys there's some
kind of a weird flow but no one's saying
anything yeah like even from them to me
maybe not I'm not putting it there but
like you know you could kind of like tip
it over it yeah yeah like and and even
they're so far away like I just feel
like energy wise like maybe this is just
like blocking my [ __ ] and I just need to
like handle this and like not why am I
still hanging on to that like yeah to
find something new so
I very kind of like I wasn't like I
officially I was like you cannot
communicate with me anymore but I was
like yeah I'm like just faded out like
keeping in touch so much and like you
know didn't really do that and then
shortly thereafter I I met a guy we did
it for a while and then like I met my
husband right when I met my husband
there was a girl who he had dated for
three years
but her family and his family were very
close so they stayed friends after that
and she was married she's married now
right and they would talk
like once a week on the phone and I was
like yeah I don't like that yeah and
they'd be on the phone for a while and
I'm like yeah this is not gonna fly with
me right so I said to him you know I
don't really like this I just don't like
it I don't feel why like why are you
guys talking this much like why are you
like a person for her she lives on the
other side of the country it's like an
emotional shooting type of thing but not
cheating and he had multiple
conversations with me thoroughly
convincing me that it was nothing it
wasn't like that just a friend at uh he
likes talking to her and I was like okay
still doesn't sit well with me it just I
don't feel good about it there's no
reason for you to have this friendship I
don't understand right it went on for a
little while longer until she came to
visit with her husband to LA and we all
went out to a bar together I felt
awkward and I and I said and I said he
goes I don't understand why I don't like
I said here's why I don't like it
because I'm the new girl and she has
history with you yeah I don't like that
I don't want to hang out with someone
who's been where I am now I don't like
that that's being totally [ __ ] honest
with you like it's just you're insecure
when you meet someone and you're trying
to like build something with them and
then when someone has that history with
the person they have this one up on you
right I okay if that makes me insecure
then I'm [ __ ] insecure I don't like
it just being honest there's no way to
not feel that way yeah so so
um we went out to a bar and then the
next day we met for lunch just my
husband and I and her and her husband
and when we got there
she said something I'm so sorry the
lunch and the bar were reverse lunch is
the first thing we did that's important
so when we got to lunch she said
she greeted him in like a weird voice
like I'm like hey like it was something
weird just being funny I guess I said
what what is I said what is that voice
or something and her husband goes oh
that's the voice she uses when she talks
to your husband
I'm sorry what
I was like okay their thing and he's
okay with this he goes my husband goes I
didn't know you did that what like I
don't know he goes okay anytime she
talks about you or whatever she has this
voice
so I'm just sitting there and I love
this because I'm like yeah exactly what
the [ __ ] I said yeah yeah so I'm just
silent and I'm just gonna let this whole
thing roll out the way it's going to
because now he sees it did the husband
say this with like kind of like the
husband was like yeah and I'm like this
is so awkward like he's okay with it or
he's like bothered he's he's like
passive aggressive
like just having resentment that's just
yes
like they've talked about it friendly
but like yeah this is my life you know
what I mean you look great so we go
through the lunch and we get home and I
said so that was interesting huh babe
and he goes
yeah he's like I had no idea that she
was doing that and I was like yeah it's
a little bit weird he's like yeah now
now it's weird
and I said okay so I'll let you handle
it
um we're supposed to go out with these
guys tomorrow night to this bar if you
don't handle it I'm definitely gonna
handle it but I'm gonna give you the
opportunity to do that so you have until
tomorrow night you're probably going to
handle a lot better than I do I can tell
you right now yeah so absolutely he so
he's like okay all right you know
because I'm like I put up with this [ __ ]
for months yeah [ __ ] phone calls and
like I'm like what are we doing yeah so
would she would she be the one that hits
him up all the time calling [ __ ] she's
like oh so and so is calling let me
leave the wrong number they all know who
they are so
um
so the next sign of the bar he goes let
me talk to her husband that's a good
idea so he went over and he talked to
him and later on he told me he was like
listen like do you think it's weird that
she and I talk and he's like yeah I
don't really like it very much the
husband and he goes yeah neither does my
you know I wasn't his wife yet but yeah
yeah and um yeah and so and so he's like
yeah it just seems like you know you
guys found an excessive amount of time
on the phone yeah like Clark here's the
thing like she should be creating on her
current marriage into the future on like
doing that yes that's what she should be
spending her time on yeah not hanging on
to some [ __ ] three and a half and
also this is the longest girlfriend
you've had there's a lot of significance
like would you feel more comfortable
just so I know like if they had never
been together like yeah it was just a
random yeah I would it's someone would
be weird okay but I would have but in
any scenario that I've run into this
there's some sort of there's something
yeah exactly we have history with the
person there's another bear in our
office does this all of his friends are
girls and he's dated almost all of them
and I'm like I don't know how many
[ __ ] current girlfriend you have is
okay with this yeah
yeah I've explained this to him a
million times I go bear it this is not
cool dude yeah you're gonna date these
girls they're not gonna you're not gonna
find your soul mate doing this I'm
telling you right now yeah whoever's
okay with this is begrudgingly okay with
it because they want a boyfriend yeah
I'm just telling you right now like so
he talks to the husband then that
happens
then he said he has a conversation with
her and he goes listen I just don't
think it's a good idea that we talk as
much like you're married like you should
create also there was people in the
family that were very surprised they
didn't end up getting married I'm like
no no no no no of course
yeah so yeah it's like meet the [ __ ]
so yeah so then they stop talking do you
know that six months later she was
pregnant they have kids now like they
have and we don't like if he like saw
her in passing he'd say hello but they
don't speak at all that's good but it
was like yeah and it was like it's way
healthier that way and she was able to
focus on her current relationship which
is what she should have been doing you
know what I mean I mean the fact that
she spent that much time still talking
to him yeah like does she even want to
be in that man that's weird this is like
the type of stuff that I was trying to
explain there's like a difference it's
not like just some weird jealous it's
not a blanket like you could never hang
out with the officers it's not like that
it's just like what's the reason for
this one
um the only thing I can think of that
kind of like happened with me and Steve
was and the very very beginning when we
first started dating he had just
gotten dumped by his long-term
girlfriend like and he'd been single for
like two three weeks when we started
dating it was like pretty fast and I
even had been like I don't I want you to
heal longer like because I really like
you and I don't want to rush into this
he had to be the rebound or whatever but
we couldn't help it like we really just
like [ __ ] hit it off on our first
date and like you guys already knew each
other yeah we knew each other for three
years yeah ahead of time so like we had
been friends like we worked on a lot of
projects together we'd both been in
serious relationships and then both
gotten dumped at the same time that kind
of thing and so we just got together
after like we shot we did a project
together and then he asked me out to a
movie and then we just like like I'm
gonna marry this guy right and so uh we
got together and his not his ex that
just dumped him but the XX like that he
was obsessed with like in his like the
one that got away like yeah like yeah
exactly but like they broke up in a
really like significant way where he was
completely over her and like when he was
with his uh four-year relationship he
even like said that he said to me when
we were friends that his ex reached out
and he said don't talk to me because I
it's encroaching on my relationship I
don't want like you know yeah and he
like sets that boundary he's like out of
respect because I thought that stood out
to me because my current boyfriend at
that time was the opposite was like you
shouldn't be jealous at all about it and
like I'm not jealous it's just like you
yeah it was like huh so I'm not crazy
like that is kind of like kind of
totally like it does kind of encroach on
the relationship right especially when
it's an X okay yeah and then um because
I'm Friends With All My Exes but we
don't talk every day we just like kind
of like if I could reach out like yeah
with them and like they reach out about
something enemies that have ever
actually exactly like we're friend
friendly except for the one but um but
yeah so anyway his XX finds out he's
single and saw him like go into some
store on Hollywood Boulevard and was
like oh my God like and DM or emailed
him or whatever and was like hey I have
a podcast now and like she's like she's
married and to this like very A-list
celebrity I think they're not together
anymore but like at that time she was
just recently married she had a podcast
and she's like hey let's catch up and
like blah blah blah and this girl I knew
the history and I wasn't jealous like he
was obsessed with her she rejected him
like like they were together for four
years anyway it didn't work out but I
was like it's kind of weird that she's
like like I was reading the messages I
was like she just seems like really
excited to see you and a little bit too
much yeah and I was like I trust you
yeah but something feels off about this
and I just want you to know you haven't
talked to her in like eight years and or
like or sorry for four or five years and
um and she's like very like it's
complementary and like like you don't
trust me yeah it seems the intention
seem a little off and he was like you
have nothing to worry about like we're
just gonna catch up I have no feelings
for her I'm like I'm not I'm not worried
about it yeah yeah but um so then he
goes and does the podcast and you know I
I actually listen to the episode because
I wanted to hear everything of course
I don't even think she knew that he had
started dating someone new because he
was so recently single like we weren't
even Facebook official yet like yeah so
like I don't even think that she knew
about me or anything and so she did ask
about if I he was dating anyone on the
show and he did answer and he said that
like yeah and like really likes his new
girlfriend blah blah so I was like okay
good um but then afterwards I was like
how'd it go and he was like yeah so
after the podcast she was showing me
around her new house because she lives
in like a mansion now and we were kind
of like talking about how like crazy it
was and um and she like a private Chef
like all this like crazy [ __ ] and uh and
she brought up his dick size and brought
up like how no one's ever been bigger
than him and
um awkward was like
you know kind of insinuating like I
don't why would you bring that up like
we are alone yeah exactly and so he's
like yeah so you were probably right and
I was he's like I immediately yes
immediately
he's like I just need you to know
because I don't want to hide anything
from you like that did happen and like I
was really awkward it was really weird
and I did had no idea that was gonna
happen I was like but I also think
there's intuition right yeah I do think
that when you care about someone yeah
even if you don't really care about them
that much but you like them and you're
good like there are people who are just
super perceptive you know and you feel
like something's off you have to trust
your gut like yeah well don't invalidate
that feeling because there's something
to it there's a reason why you feel it
you know is 100 correct yeah yeah I
don't know if I've ever been wrong with
my interview yeah it's like there's a
reason why you have that you know what I
mean like I thought it was weird that
they were still talking and then when he
found out that there was a weird voice
that she did then he saw it yeah you
can't force someone else to realize
something yeah but you it's like how do
they respond to your you communicating a
concern do they give enough of a [ __ ] to
go like all right I'll keep an eye out
yeah I don't think there's anything but
thank you yeah and then when they when
it does happen like that was great that
he was like [ __ ] you're right like
there was something yeah you've easily
been like brushed it off and be like
what no I didn't notice that exactly she
was just being funny exactly exactly
yeah and I do have a big dick let's be
honestly
it is pretty impressive
um but yeah like people like oh like
well you guys have a really no personal
sex like no because like like Jess has
called up my husband like about like a
breakup or whatever like and you're fine
she's going through and it's like I'm
not like why are you talking just like
it's not no it's not yeah frequent no
it's not like twice ever
twirling his hair on the bed
crying I'm crying like snot's coming
down my nose and I'm like I don't
understand men yeah baby baby it's gonna
be okay
did you know I have a really big dick
yeah
I will send you a picture that'll make
you feel better
probiotic contain clinically studied
strains uh well meet one that does
rituals symbiotic plus contains two of
the world's most studied strains with
over 350 publications of human clinical
trials that's a lot of Trials I love
ritual absolutely love ritual have been
taking their vitamins for over five
years now I started on the regular
Women's Multivitamin and then moved to
the prenatal and I have never met a
better vitamin squares and then to add
the probiotics on top of that which is
something that I don't think many people
realize how important it is for your gut
health as somebody who struggled through
sibo which is small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth I didn't even know that gut
health was a thing that I should be
focused on probiotics were just
something that my mom talked about after
I got off of antibiotics and like you
have to like slowly integrate them with
yogurt or whatever I didn't really
understand it but now I totally get it
it's so essential for balancing your gut
health and finding a good one is like
finding the Holy Grail like you have
have to find a good one they're not all
the same they're not all made the same
and so having this many Publications
with clinical trials is so great to just
back up why this one is the best
um it's more than just a probiotic it's
a three in one there's clinically
studied prebiotics probiotics and
post-biotics to support your balanced
gut microbiome look it up Google it it's
a single nested in a minty capsule which
one of the things I love is opening the
ritual bottle and smelling it because
it's all minty and it just makes your
day better and it's designed to thrive
so there's a delayed release capsule
designed to help reach the colon not the
stomach a lot of ones if it releases too
early it does it in your stomach it's
not where you want it and an ideal place
for a probiotics to survive and grow is
in your colon and it's designed with
moisture controlled bottle technology to
protect the probiotic strains symbiotic
plus and ritual are here to celebrate
not hide your insides there's no more
shame in your gut game that's why ritual
is offering our list centers 10 off
during your first three months visit
ritual.com big mood to start ritual or
add symbiotic plus to your subscription
today that's ritual.com
b-i-g-m-o-o-d do it all right next one I
once met a girl who thought it was a red
flag that I always placed my phone
screen down on a table she thought it
meant I was hiding something I had to
try and explain that it's too big to
keep in my pocket and it's screened down
to be polite and show her that she has
my undivided attention yeah I like that
she's projecting the insecurity from the
last guy that cheated on it exactly
that's so funny because or she might
have done that when she cheated on
someone else yeah you know what I mean
like it could go either way yeah I get
so weird around people's phones like
this person I'm talking to now he'll
just like [ __ ] leave this [ __ ]
straight up with the the sound on and
all that stuff and I'm like here dang
and I'm like
nope yeah because it also comes down to
like there's a manners thing about it
too right if you're dating someone and
that's happening you're like okay my so
I do like and even being married like my
husband sometimes is on the phone I have
to be like babe babe hey can I tell you
something can you put the phone now for
a second you know what I mean like yeah
so dating someone like going back to
those days of being like yeah I think it
would be a sign of kind of respect and
show me my importance that like you put
that down and now it's just us
especially nowadays when people are so
addicted to their friends they're
constantly like looking at them yeah I
did go on a date one time where this guy
was on his phone the entire time and I
was like okay well clearly you're not
wow interested like why did we even
that's why did you even ask me out yeah
exactly even now like when I go to
dinner like with another couple that's
been married for a billion years like we
don't we're like put your [ __ ] phone
away yeah we're at a nice restaurant
like let's interact with you humans like
stop you know it's like rude yeah that's
so true yeah also the Light bothers me
when the notifications pop up yeah I
personally always put my phone down
because yeah it's distracting yeah I
know that I'm gonna stop listening to
you because I'm gonna be like is that
just you know the [ __ ] Zillow app or
is it important is it important you know
like I need to know what it is okay next
one not wanting your partners is to have
the passwords to all your social media
accounts it's just weird my husband and
I sometimes leave things open on shared
devices and each of us just respectfully
logs out and logs in with our own
credentials we don't open each other's
mail either there's a basic level of
respect and trust you need to have in a
relationship I think it's the old flag
that you would even have that
conversation well I was just give me
your password like 100 who cares right
okay what's what's the red flag
uh not wanting your partner to have your
password okay so we're saying I'm just
yeah is me dating Jess and going like
what's your Facebook password yeah
like how does that come up even exactly
I just want to know if we're dating and
we're serious that we're gonna have each
other's past yeah now we exchange
passwords right yeah like what who's
doing that are you 15 years old right
nobody cares yeah this is like a
childhood problem exactly I mean this
must not be my generation someone says
relationships still need privacy if you
can't trust your partner enough to allow
them that you are simply in the wrong
relationship yeah or you're just not
healed enough to be with anyone yeah
yeah you got some some stuff going on
there if this is what your priorities
are like a password to a [ __ ] social
media account yeah you have trauma for
sure and like opening each other's mail
like okay also that might be a federal
offense but I mean if it's not like like
my like sometimes my husband like for
instance my husband's got the DMV thing
the other day I knew it was his
registration and I do all the finances
so I opened it I [ __ ] paid your
registration you know what I mean like
it depends when you're married you're a
unit though yeah yeah it's different if
your stuff is my stuff I think about
dating I guess right yeah dating opening
mail would be very [ __ ] yeah that's
weird
even if they're talking about email
that's still weird yeah it's super weird
all right next one is the amount of
women I know that take it as a red flag
that a guy doesn't pay for all dates
slash buy them things ellipses I'm proud
of I'm proud of what I have done with my
life and that I can go do those things
myself I like I like a guy that treats
me as an equal that is not a red flag at
all to me uh I mean if a guy is not
paying for dates that shouldn't be like
if the entitlement is I mean like if
they feel entitled to that I guess
that's kind of like
oh you're talking about like the guy's a
red flag for not paying for [ __ ] I think
that's a red flag for that they are
entitled for the guy to pay for
everything yeah because you know like
Society wise how like things are
different people assume that the guy
should always pay yeah and if the guy
doesn't pay then they consider that is
this the first date second date third
day or is this like date 97 I think it
matters
like the first I don't know five dates
the first date I I believe it should be
by invitation if I asked you to a date
I'm paying if you asked me to a date
then you're paying because I invited you
or you invited me I'm not painful
although I always offer to pay for half
um Steve was the very first person that
paid ever paid for a meal for me here's
what I think I think that as a woman you
should make the reach meaning like go
for the wallet yeah and if you're not
turned down yeah and absolutely not I'm
paying it says the man yeah get out of
there yeah because after a while yeah I
think you'd be like oh we want to go
we'll split [ __ ] pizza or whatever
we'll go dutch and like whatever fine
when you're together yeah yeah I am a
little bit old-fashioned that way like I
do think that it's like
I don't know it's just like you want to
be like treated like a princess and like
take it on like Take Me Out Show
intentions and an investment yeah and I
guess like if you originated like the
woman was like hey do you want to go out
for coffee yeah and you get to coffee
and you don't you're not sure about this
at all you don't know if it's gonna go
anywhere and you buy your own coffee
okay fine that's right I wouldn't like I
think it would be it wouldn't be a deal
breaker for me at all for me to buy my
coffee yeah but if this is like dinner
or like something nice and I wouldn't
mind necessarily for the guy to go like
no no I'll get your coffee like oh well
thanks but I also then would feel like I
don't even think that I feel obligated
to do because yeah that's what I was
scared of before and yeah but like now
after having been courted like yeah
proper like way of the traditional way
excuse me I'm like yeah it feels good
it's it's less about the money yes
yeah it's the gesture and the like you
know the biologically like this this man
is capable of like protecting me or
putting yeah
and like not that he needs to but he
wants to yeah primal thing yeah 100 yeah
and like I want to get dressed up for
him yeah I have to yeah I can just show
up in my freaking sweats if I wanted to
actually because I'm a person that can
make my own decisions but yeah I want to
you want to create extra miles exactly
and so I feel like that courting stage
is just like it's a little bit of a
dance but it's kind of like it's the
only time you get to do that dance
because yeah after you're married like
we still try to court each other like we
still have like this whole like date
night thing where yeah we want that
romance to stay alive but like you know
you get very comfortable and like it you
don't have those type of feelings like I
don't know if it's gonna work out I
don't know yeah I'm kind of nervous you
know like you don't have that stuff
anymore and so it's kind of a fun phase
and like to have someone putting in the
airplane yeah yeah it's just showing
like hey I'm I'm meeting you halfway I'm
putting in the effort you're putting in
there and we're both putting an effort
and that makes us feel good and stable
and like that yeah move forward I love
that I mean this obviously applies to
just normal traditional like
I guess hetero relationships or whatever
anything outside of that I don't know I
don't fully understand you know gay
relationships or whatever but if I if a
man a straight man is trying to date me
and on already date two or something
he's like you want to split like you you
don't like me I know you don't like me
you never just hanging out as friends
and now we're just hanging out as
friends like this is not going anywhere
at what point it would be acceptable for
you
I think it would be like if we're in a
relationship and it's been like three
months and I haven't pulled out my
wallet for a goddamn thing and he's like
hey babe how about you get dinner
tonight you know and it's months later
we're like yeah really in this when he
forgets and he's he's like he's like I'm
literally paying out the nose for every
[ __ ] goddamn thing you want to help
out a little bit like okay yeah you've
been there you've made your investment
actually like on a second or third date
I had like it was like three activities
right it was like a movie like the bar
and then like something else and like so
I finally pulled out my credit card for
like the third thing and I was like I'll
get this thing yeah and it was in the
beginning but I'm like well you've
already did you're doing it
it's kind of like I can get the ice
cream you know what I mean so it's like
little [ __ ] like that that was nice it's
fine too it's just a show like hey I'm
here too yeah but like they'll try to
take advantage of it the whole thing is
not hey you're gonna help me pay for
this [ __ ] you know yeah like you know
my sister went on a date and the guy was
like oh I don't have my wallet like at
the end oh yeah she's like okay but now
she met this guy yeah and now she and he
was missing a finger by the way a crazy
story
yeah exactly
um so I was like you probably sold it
like yeah
for the [ __ ] coffee so she this guy
she's dating now she's like he he does
all these really super fun dates with
her like takes her on all they went to a
concert they're doing this they're doing
that yeah and he will not let her pay
for anything yeah and she texts me she's
like oh I always offer and I said no
dude this is the way I should be I love
this I'm so glad you're experiencing
Matt because you've experienced the
other side of that so much to enjoy that
exactly and I love that you keep
offering that's wonderful you know what
I mean but just like yes be like thank
you you're obviously grateful he wants
to do it for you he wants to create
these wonderful memories with you and be
like financially responsible for doing
that let him do that and someone has
like the joy of giving that yeah it's
like you're robbing them of that Joy
exactly it's not a guy that's like it's
different if you're like the girl that's
like well you didn't even buy me a
tennis bracelet yet it's like that yeah
totally totally then you're just an
[ __ ]
sugar baby yeah yeah next one is finding
other people attractive while in a
monogamous relationship not actually
cheating but just simply finding other
people attractive a lot of people think
that that means they'll immediately
cheat or are thinking about cheating no
that's not how that works people
monogamous or polyamorous are going to
be attracted to more than one person
that's just how people are the choices
they make around set attraction is a
different story but seriously people who
get jealous of their partner finding
other people attractive are a way too
insecure to be in a relationship B to
immature to be in a relationship and see
ourselves are they talking about time or
they like oh my God the neighbors so
this is context for sure my husband and
I constantly I'm like look at her she's
looking at her she's a great [ __ ]
body don't say it and he's like he's
like yeah like he doesn't whatever and
he's like yeah but we could admire a
beautiful place exactly a male or female
you know what I mean like he'll say to
me like look at that that is a [ __ ]
man and I'm like he's like I'm like that
is that is a [ __ ] man yeah yeah
it's your gender yeah
and then it's together but we'll also
jump around like we're at Rite Aid one
day and there was a girl who who walked
past him and said something like hi and
I was like do you know her and he's like
no and I was like okay wow and because
he said hi back and she was really
pretty and I was like cool and I was
like and I was like just [ __ ] be
careful there okay
and then it was so funny because like
weeks later he tells this story it's so
funny we were out somewhere like a
Target or something and he goes and I
was like there was a girl in the island
I was like oh my God she's like really
she's calling a nice ass and then he's
like then I realized it's my it was it
was me
and he's like and there's a whole
running joke about how he'll dream he'll
have dreams and he's like I can't even
[ __ ] cheat on you in my dreams he's
like I've had a dream there was this
beautiful woman on top of me completely
naked and I'm going so I can't do this I
I'm married please get off of me in my
[ __ ] dream and I'm like I'm so sorry
to hear that baby that's wonderful that
is my thing I have dreams were like
Leonardo DiCaprio was like please come
to dinner with me I'm like I'm married
yeah I cannot do that but mine was Brad
Pitt yeah like I'm like God damn it I
had an opportunity in my dream no I
might have said mine was 90s Brad Pitt
damn it oh that was a good one no but
that's a good time because a similar
story so Casey and I like earlier in our
relationship we went to some fair or
something and we passed by like there
was like a mirror and he he was like
staring at the mirror and I was just
like but like the way the mirror was set
up like he couldn't tell that it was me
but he just kept staring at my back and
but I could see him stare I can't
remember clearly something like this the
point is like a fun house mirror thing
it was like it was like a wind chime
kind of thing so it was like oh yeah
yeah so it wasn't like a steady like
static mirror and then I don't know how
it came out but you ended up like he
ended up telling me like okay I just
thought that she was really pretty but
then he realized it was me I was like
that's cute but don't be checking out
girls yeah
and I don't think it's like I have a
story by the way I've learned a DiCaprio
bought me a drink and I was out of the
bar with someone
because I was there with a guy and and
that probably crushed him that guy does
no longer exist the bartender said this
is from Leonardo DiCaprio didn't work
out and I should have just and I
couldn't because I was the best thing to
do and I'm not that kind of person
I was at do you want to tell a story yes
so I was at this [ __ ] bar God damn it
I hate this story I know what if it was
what if I served them what if it was
that because I served him in a bar I was
a cocktail waitress and he would he came
into the bar and like yeah so maybe yeah
so what city is this it's in L.A I don't
remember the name of the bar but there
was a band playing and there was a band
playing and so shut up
I don't remember so no no it was like it
might have been like a not a vipery room
type place but something like very like
there was just a bar and a stage and
that was it yes okay okay so let's take
the journey and we'll see okay so I'm
just standing there because the [ __ ]
bass player um was a friend of my of my
dates okay right and so we went to go
see his friend the drummer was a very
good friend of Leonardo DiCaprio's and
staying at his house okay this guy was
only a piano player so it's okay
yeah so Lena Gabriel walks in with his
mom and his girlfriend now is 25 year
old girlfriend we're younger
so I
am not like at that time I was
definitely not anything like his type
because she's like a toothpick with
blonde hair and she just goes for days
you know her legs just yeah everywhere
and so but it's only on a Caprio so I
was like he's my type so
um I'm there with this guy that I was
dating at the time and he goes wanting
to go to the bar and get some drinks and
I was like yep and so I go over and I'm
not a Beer Drinker but they were just
ordering beer and I was like I'll have
like a Corona with lime because that's
what [ __ ] girls just don't drink beer
so I go over to the bar and I can't get
the waitresses at the bartender's
attention because it's so busy and only
are the cappers at the bar so clearly he
takes precedence to my order right so
I'm standing there and he had a baseball
cap on like a navy blue sweater and he
comes now Aviator had just come out oh
so Titanic's like a long time ago we
have to know that for this for because
I'm such an idiot when I have this bad
habit of like when I'm uncomfortable I
tell like a joke to try to be funny but
it's always awkward and I thought my
mouth and it's a disaster so I'm
standing there and I'm waiting for my
turn and he's standing next to me and
I'm just like sweating you know and and
I'm so cool it's fine like I'm trying to
like you know and um
so
um and I'm like looking over them like
the guy I'm dating is like really far
away and I'm like okay so he goes he
talks to the bartender and he orders
whatever he's ordering for him and his
[ __ ] mom which is so cute that he
brought his mom and and he goes in and
he goes no are you waiting to order what
would you like I'm sorry and he's like
what would you like and I was like oh I
was just gonna get a Corona with with
lime like I feel like such a douchebag
right so he's like oh and a Corona
online for he's like what's your name
and I was like I was like Janine it's
Jay whatever Janine it's my real life so
um he's like it's nice to meet you I'm
Leo and I go yeah getting this [ __ ] I
know I go and he goes oh he's like sorry
and I go yeah no it's fine you were the
guy from the movie with the boat like
I'm so cold never let go Jack that whole
bit that's what came out of my mouth and
he's like from the movie with the boat
and I was like yeah and he's like he
goes I like that that's really funny
because obviously it's the tight yeah
it's not a [ __ ] boat right but I just
was like so like I don't know and I was
like just be funny yeah yeah
to him all the time
in the Moment Like Aviator just came out
you [ __ ] idiot he's gonna make the
plane not the boat yeah I should have
been like you're the guy with the movie
from The Grapes what are we talking
about
so he goes he's like he goes you're
really funny and he's like are you here
with anyone I said unfortunately yes I
am here with someone and um and he's
like oh it's too bad I was like yep and
uh and he's like and then she comes and
he he goes just put it on my tab and I
go to no I can buy my own beer thank you
very much I don't need the belt money
he was like no no I got it and I was
like okay
I was like thank you so much he's like
it was really great to meet you I was
like you too and I went over the other
side and I just hated my the rest of my
night yeah of course I was side eyeing
the whole time in front of you is
[ __ ] idiot it's like hey everybody
yeah okay and uh I'm just like this is
you ruin this and my sister loves this
story and she's like you could have been
with Leah and I'm like shut the [ __ ] up
25th birthday
how old are you at the time I was uh
like 22 it would have been yeah
his girlfriend he was there with some
Gisele looking I might have bench
yourself yeah um
I can't hold a [ __ ] candle too dude I
mean so I was like I'm I mean I eat too
much and I'm not tall enough and it's
fine I mean he didn't like curvy women
then so whatever but he liked me and I
made him laugh and he was like yeah
asked if I was there for it with anyone
I was like why are we all gonna like
yeah party with your mom like what are
you wearing what are the options here
mine uh was right after I had my dream
where I wouldn't because it wasn't like
yeah it was we just manifested him into
real yeah well so in my dream it was
like so he was like come to dinner with
me and I was like no I have a boyfriend
and then he tricked me into having
dinner with me by saying it was a
business thing because I was an actor so
I was like okay what's the business
thing so then I go to dinner and it was
like this romantic dinner and I'm like
Leo like you this is a date is this a
dream
he's like please like I just like I just
can't stop thinking about you like all
this stuff's like of course boyfriend
and then I woke up and I was like God
damn it yeah I go to work the next week
it was like three days later and he
comes in like oh you're a cocktails I
was at the bar and it was 22.
blue eyes piercing through my freaking
into yourself and the first thought of
my head was like I said I have a
boyfriend
did you not hear me
[Laughter]
yeah but I was like oh my God like are
my dreams reality this is a wild witch
oh my God that's amazing so did he speak
to you he did he was with a crowd of
people that like he had a whole
Entourage but the guy that was doing the
performance was his friend or like I
guess like also a piano guys yeah the
Piano guy anyway there were a lot of
a-listers there that um were friends
with this Piano guy and uh it was a
piano Guy like Billy Joel no his name
was erock I actually just saw um a
billboard for him in Las Vegas I can't
think he was performing but I was like
hey that's okay yeah but um yeah the the
so there was like he was with an
Entourage and he wrote a double Gray
Goose with lime and uh ordered four of
them and each time I swear he looked me
right in the eye when he's the thing but
like piercingly like yeah
I was just like do you remember me from
your dreams
like I was like you know
no not me like you freaking he freaking
knows like yeah we know
yeah all right guys well that's our show
make sure to check out Jay at jokes by
Jay at Instagram and Tick Tock she's
super funny highly recommend her stuff
also make sure to check out our sponsors
and like and comment we'll see you guys
next time bye
foreign
[Music]